la mode je lance cette année la robe
l'homme pas du matin au soir avec ce que
j'appelle du méridienne c'est une robe
qui permet d'affronter toutes les
circonstances de la vie lorsque les
présidents directeurs généraux
consentiront bien entendu à accepter
leur personnel comme ça les gens à
convaincre sont donc les pdg
je crois que je suis content tout les
ségrégations qu'elle soit la ségrégation
de la couleur qu'elle soit la série à
sion du sexe je ne dis pas qu'il faut
saviez comme ça je dis on peut
s'habiller comme ça c'est ma révolution
est ce que vous en pensez qu'il est
ridicule
pourquoi est ce qu'ils n'en avaient pas
assez lubamba je suis un peu vieux
m'enfin si j'étais plus jeune oui mais
c'est affreux ne jouerait pas m'habiller
comme ça pas du tout ce dont vous aurez
un mari est ce que vous aimeriez qu'ils
soient à veiller comme ça c'est tous les
départs hey pourquoi pas marquer que ça
s'est déjà fait l'europe pour faire pour
en main de toute façon c'est pas ce
n'est qu'un commencement
la mode n'est qu'un éternel
recommencement définit comme moi je
trouve qu'il faut avoir du courage de
côté marrant c'est fou le carnaval chez
nous sera pas du moins de co2 que vous
passiez votre temps à faire des choses
pareilles mais moi je ne fais rien du
tout là dedans ce couturier qui fait
rêver le couturier settama les gares
deviennent de plus en plus féminin s'est
vu des mecs fallait emballer en jupe
comme ça vous pouvez passer ridicule que
je trouve ridicules c'est que ce soit
ridicule alors pourquoi vous habiller
pas de cette façon-là a je n'ai pas le
droit avant lundi et à partir de lundi
on pourra vous voir apparaître lundi
serait comme ça on en reparle enfin vous
savez moi je suis aussi ou un peu comme
picasso je ne ressemble pas forcément
mes tableaux